Hey, what's going on it's Bill Burr and
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday, Monday
morning podcast. And
I'm just checking in on you. I'm
just checking in here. Sorry,
I'm just checking in on you to
seeing how you of weeks ago.
A little half hour checking in.
How you doing? How you doing? Okay.
Fed fucking tastic. You know it's funny,
I'm always a day late and
a dollar short to shit,
so I fucking got a youtube page now.
Um, we're doing all this animation.
I'm fucking hiring people to do stuff.
Try to get this fucking thing going so
someday I won't even have to leave my
house. All I gotta do is just sit here,
ramble on about crazy shit as I slip
into fucking senility and I'll still be
able to eat my apple sauce.
I'll still be able to pay for some
fucking applesauce. All right?
That is what, that, that is what
the old age is all about. Okay?
You don't leave your house, but
checks is still coming in. Okay?
You got a cupboard full of fucking
applesauce. Once you open them,
you put them in the fridge. You know,
even though it hurts your teeth, right?
Cause you got fucking nerve involvement
and all you fucking, I get teeth, right?
You go back to eating the same shit
you used to eat as a baby. It's just,
it's like apple sauce is Gerber
food for fucking old people, right?
So you got that. What else do you have?
You mixed a little Manet's in there and
either you don't have to fucking Choo.
Um, so I'm getting the youtube
page going and, and you know what?
These fucking constant youtube do know if,
I can't even tell you they got this
thing where they decide if what the fuck
happened on your thing is,
is a little too offensive.
Like they fucking decide and then
you don't get any of the ad money.
And I'm like, but the ads still
there, who gets the money?
Youtube keeps it fucking unbelievable.
I'll tell you right fucking now the
number one commandment broken it.
I'm telling you, it's stealing. And
this more stealing that goes on,
on the legal side of business fee,
everybody's always make going fucking
Scorsese. He's always doing that,
you know, whatever that fucking song is.
I could go from rags to riches.
That's what the hell it is, right?
All that good fellas. Shit, fuck you
pay me. Fuck you pay me all of that.
Like that doesn't exist
in the legal world.
It's even fucking worst and it's more
overt that it's just straight up fucking
stealing. So I don't know what I'm
going to do with the youtube page.
I'm actually thinking, what am I,
why don't I just move it to
my fucking website? Right.
I'll reach out to fucking Matt Miller
high life. You want to fucking, uh,
you want to fucking just be on all
my videos and I'll just do it on my,
my page and I can do say whatever the
fuck I want and not worry about somebody
taking my fucking
retirement applesauce money.
It's not like I'm making
any fucking money anyways.
You got to have like a billion hits,
I think to make $7. Well, you know,
you got to cure rate as
they're talking to you here.
Like a cash machine going off in
the fucking background, whatever.
Who gives a shit. All right. You know
what? I am actually in a great mood here.
I am in a great mood. And, um,
despite that highway robbery,
youtube, she called it your
tube to your fucking bullshit.
You're keeping all the
fucking money, your cons, um,
who gives a shit right at the end of
the fucking day? Well, obviously you do,
Bill, you wouldn't have brought
it up. I don't fucking mind. Just,
just fuck me over. Why
can't you just fuck me over?
Why can't you just come out and just say,
listen, we're going to fuck you over.
Why do you to lie?
Why do you got to sit there and
act like you're not going to do it?
And then you turn around and you
do it. That's what upsets me.
It's not that you're doing it.
Okay.
So you said you weren't going
to do it. Alright, anyways, uh,
Brad Marshawn suspended for two games
for stab and Jake Dodgen in the balls.
So he got one game for each balls, each
ball that he fucking stabbed him. And,
and uh, it makes sense. I know a lot of
people like, why didn't Sidney Crosby?
Cause what Sidney did don't you see as
he turned his fucking stick sideways and
he gave him a little tap, a
little tap of the ball back,
like the same level that when you know
the doctor, you go to get a physical,
he as you cross your legs and you know
he hits you and your knee goes up. Right?
Just like that. He was just
testing the guy's reflexes.
So he gets no suspension
or a penalty, you know,
plus he has those big pouty lips
and everybody feels bad for him.
That's the genius to Sidney Crosby.
Sidney Crosby has a look on his face,
you know, like right before you make
your girlfriend cry and then you're like,
oh my God, she's going to cry. So
you just abandon your argument.
Like that's what his face looks like.
So I think that's why he's able,
that's why he's able to get away with
what he gets away with. Plus, you know,
he's a superstar and he makes everybody
a ton of money. So Brad Marshawn,
you know, you live by the sword, you die
by the sword. I remember branded press,
fucking stabbed them in the nuts, uh,
when we will play in Vancouver
a couple of years ago.
And then what's funny is still listen
to Jack Edwards when he sees Marshawn,
he's such a fucking homer.
He's just sitting to go, oh,
look at all that is
blatantly out of the rules.
That is a delicious video
for the boys in New York.
Hope you enjoy your day off.
You're talking about
definitely a suspension and a,
and then marsh shun wave, you
know, fucking just, I mean,
he uppercutted this dude's nuts.
His stick was not on the flat side.
Like he was giving it
a backhand or you know,
he did an upper cut with the stick
to the guy's Tatun ball area. And,
um, like, you know,
when your wife tells you to shovel the
driveway and you're already pissed at
you,
you know how hard you throw those first
two fucking scoops of snow over your
shoulder. That's how hard he hit
this guy in the fucking nuts.
And I gotta tell you as a Bruins
Fan, I thought I was like, oh my God,
he just fucked us over cause he
just got kicked out of the game.
I think it was still zero to zero
against the Tampa Bay lightning.
And we were waiting to, um, you know,
see if we were gonna make the playoffs.
I'm like, Oh my God, you just got to give
right at the end of the first period.
I'm like, he's going to get kicked
out. That's going to fucking know,
give Tampa a little jumping.
They'll their, their game.
They're going to win this fucking game.
He's going to be out for the rest of the
season. And, uh, and then we're gonna,
you know, I catastrophize in my
head, what if we fucking, you know,
don't make the playoffs
because of that playoff.
But fortunately we ended up winning I
think four to one and four to nothing.
And, um, if we beat Ottawa tonight,
we can actually, uh, you know,
we at the very least, uh, are,
are going to be a wild card.
But I mean I don't, obviously,
I don't feel like playing
fucking the capitols right now.
They looking like world beaters, but
um, eventually you will have to play it,
but it'd be nice to maybe have a
chance to win a playoff series.
We'll see how we do though. You
never know goaltenders can get,
they get hot at the right time in here.
There's no telling how far you could
go in the Stanley Cup playoffs.
Um, I feel like for me, I just feel that,
um, that's actually become
part of my vocabulary now.
Cause every time Nia watches
those fucking reality shows,
people just go for me or Tinky I just
feel, and now I've done it so much,
now I'm doing it. So I am officially
bill Kardashians right now. All right.
I'm not thinking about
transitioning. I'm not going to die.
What's left of my fucking, I got my,
got my head shaved now by my beard.
I'm not gonna dry dyed
fucking jet black, you know,
but like at Kardashians I did
marry an African American,
so I feel like I'm halfway there.
I think I could actually say that I'm
one of their cousins. I don't know. Oh,
I see a Photoshop coming
anyways, um, to get back to,
uh, to the hockey. Um, and so yeah,
so we're in the playoffs for the
first time in three fucking years,
so it's great to be in there and
hopefully we'll be Ottawa tonight. And uh,
I bet Marshawn cost himself a little
bit of fucking money there. You know,
I would think in his contract that he
gets a bonus if he gets 40 goals and the
man was sitting on 39, we're
going to play Ottawa tonight.
Forget about the rest of the game that
he could have played in Tampa playing
Ottawa tonight. And according
to the puck off podcast,
hosted by Joe Barnick on the all things
comedy network, he said that, uh,
auto has got a lot of injuries in
their defense. Who knows? Who knows?
So I guess what you take away from all
of that is that if you're in the NHL,
if you're going to fucking
hit somebody's ball bag,
you do it with the flat side of the
stick. All right? You get yourself,
you know, some collagen injections
in the ellipse like a Kardashians.
I don't know. Maybe they did. It
didn't, I dunno. Um, you know,
so you look like you're about ready to
cry like Cindy Crosby and you will not
get suspended. All right.
But I guess you heard Crosby does
and they fucking slashed somebody.
You almost took the end of his fucking,
like the guys that ended the guy's
finger was hanging off. You know,
I'm going to go out on a limb and say
that guy, he's going to have a uh,
there's not really like any of the
goons anymore. These to have like that.
That's like players like Crosby's just
have like security like back in the day
in like the 80s, like the fucking
tough guys back in the 80s, where like
they did everything but just have like
blue blazers on in ear pieces standing
next to the goal scores. If
you went anywhere near them,
they'd fucking murder you. And
I'm, I'm trying to think of who,
who the penguins have penguins
never really had a goon.
They had a bunch of fucking knee breakers.
They were really into like, well,
we're not going to fight you.
We're just gonna end your career,
blow out your fucking knee boards,
you and that type of shit. Filthy,
filthy fucking franchise. But you know,
the penguin is a dirty bird, isn't it?
Sort of the pigeon of
the Antarctic, isn't it?
Did you guys hear their buildings
on luxury condos down there?
Luxury condos in Antarctica? You
know, people in Silicone Valley,
they don't know where
else to spend their money.
They already bought up San Francisco.
They're starting to come down here to
la and a for a summer place because San
Francisco so fucking cold. Um, that the
next thing that they're going to do,
they're gonna be down in
Antarctica. You can look it up.
It's true luxury condos in
Antarctica and a la to Antartica.
They're going to have the first direct
flight in July. All of that is true.
I'm not making this up at all because
I have a half hour to a to fill up here
and I'm only 10 minutes in. I would
never do that to you guys. Um, all right,
let's talk about, oh, Billy
beef. K Care. All right.
Fucking Dad Bod Magoo who uh,
after his European run last Selma
is up to a fucking 190 pounds.
And then I kinda started working
out, getting ready for my special.
I got down to like a buck
78 finished the special.
And are they really specials anymore now
that there's one coming out every week?
It was just sort of
bill talks for an hour,
I think since my special
came out in January,
there's been 97 other hour long specials.
I think there's been out one
out every day. Um, anyways,
so I uh, I got down to a buck 78,
79 ish and uh, and then
I was just like, oh,
right now I'm waiting to
become a dad. You know,
my wife was in the third trimester,
so I'm going to try meth.
I'm going to fucking blame her a
little bit, even though I don't,
I was just drinking too much everything.
So I got up to like a backup
to like a buck 85 buck 86.
So now last week I got
myself down to 180 pounds.
This week I wanted to lose at
least two pounds. All right.
The way in is tomorrow, but uh, I'll
just start doing them on Thursday.
So I wanted to get down to one 78
maybe one 77 got on the scale today.
One 77.6.
All right, so I am,
I got one day on a film coming up.
Oh, aren't you fancy, Bill? Yes, I am.
I got one day at a film. So
ultimately, you know, I need to be,
to not get too much shit on Twitter
about being a big Booz headed fucking
baldheaded red cunt, you know,
which always fucking happens.
All these fucking actresses fucking
bitch moaning and complaining like the
Internet has only mean to them. I swear
to God, fucking self-involved lunatics,
right? Um, I gotta get
down to like my fight once,
usually about a buck 72 on camera. If
I walk around a buck 75, you know, um,
if you just see me coming down
the street, I look radiant. Okay.
You're gonna look at me like Jesus.
Bill, are you expecting book at that?
Look on your face. I'm fucking
with you. But I got to get,
but on camera I gotta be
down to a buck 72. All right.
And every fucking actor knows what
fucking wait, you gotta be at c, you know,
and you'll all get all,
you just gauge it on social media feedback
cause you're just going to get a ton
of shit. The second you
go, a little power dude,
you look like Vince Vaughn in the end
of the fucking a, the breakup. You know,
that was my favorite part of that
fucking movie. I love that fucking movie.
I loved how Vince did the fucking,
he had the a not in a relationship
fucking, you know, out there crushing ass.
And then when he was in the relationship,
he had that extra 10 to 15, you know,
the Netflix, wait, let's
sit here and you know,
make some Mac and cheese
and play footsie. Um,
I don't wanna ruin the end of the movie,
but that's one of the best, you know.
And that was a chick flick too,
cause it was about a relationship.
And that's one of my favorite things
about it was it played out in a real way.
Right down to the, you know, when he's
not in a relationship, he's fucking,
you know, he's at his
fighting weight. You know,
I'm trying to attract somebody
to fuck me again. Okay.
You were a layup so I had
my layup extra 15 on right.
That's what I'm trying to lose right
now. Little Billy layup weight.
So I'm down to one 77.6 so next week
the official way in is on Friday,
but I'll do them on
Thursday just to give a,
just add a little excitement in your
life because I'm so self involved and I
feel like you guys actually
give a shit. So do it with me.
Lose two pounds this week
at least if not three.
So I want to be down to about a buck 74
a by Friday next week and then we shoot
the following week. So I could
actually be down to one 73 you know,
if I puke behind a dumpster, you
know, take the old fucking, you know,
you know what route, I
guess you can't even see.
You can't even say bulemia without
people freaking out unless you're like,
it's one of the worst of the those. You
can't even use it as a comedy reference.
Are you allowed to, are you allowed to
say, you know, use that as a reference.
Like I'll go, I'll go if
I have to, if I have to,
I will make myself fucking Yak for fucking
a day to get down to the buck 72 to
deliver my line and a half on this movie.
Bill Burger King of the line in a half.
If you've got a line in a half that
you need to fucking be delivered by a
tertiary character. Did I use that
word correctly? I am your fucking man.
I will show up on time in
shape, ready to fucking work.
I'll show up at my fighting weight
of one 72 I will deliver that line.
I'll even give you a look. All right.
He gave me like a special and special
appearance by bill borough and the opening
credits, whatever the fuck that is
called, I will actually throw in,
I'll give you, I'll give
you the rock, you know,
with one of my invisible eyebrows that
you can't really see. Um, yeah. Anyway,
so I'm going to get down to that.
I'm going to get down to
hopefully like a book, whatever.
Okay.
72 whatever. Look at me. I
sound like the fucking Raymond,
but that's the only way to do it.
And then eventually I'd like to
get down to one, a buck 68. Okay.
And then not do what I always do
to be like, oh, I'm a buck 68,
you know, who wants some fucking cookies?
Let's get a fucking 12 pack,
you know? And then I just,
I slowly but surely go
right back up and uh, and I,
I have to make a lifestyle
change. I just feel like for me,
I'm going to be a lot happier if I cut
out gluten and I still don't know what
gluten is.
Okay.
It's some sort of chemical
that's in wheat, I believe.
And evidently it's not good for you,
even though wheat is is from the earth,
but you know there are poisonous plants
or is gluten like some shit that some
fucking nerds made for psychopaths that
have food companies that adds to the
density or some shit and somehow they
make more money. Is that what it is?
But always looking to do that shit.
Okay.
You know what I mean? You can't fucking
satisfying these fucking lunatic.
These fucking guys did. The men
at the top of these corporations,
you know what they like? They
like a bunch of fucking broads,
you know what I mean? Like no matter
what they have, they never fucking happy.
You know,
you got straight hair now you want
curly hair and now you want short hair.
You know they ain't want to wear a crop
top that you want to fucking, you know,
have clam digger zone. I, I don't, I
don't know what the fuck is she doing?
Can you just put on a fucking pair of
sweatpants and just sit down for five
fucking minutes? You know, hard.
My wife would be laughing at this shit
right now because I'm the one who I,
I fucking
the coat look like this is supposed to
be my relaxed energy right now and I'm
still talking to fast. Whenever I listened
back to my podcast, I'm like, why?
Why do I talk so fast? I thought I
w I thought I talked a lot slower.
I need to have like
cocktail party energy now.
Even at cocktail party, you gotta yell.
You got to yell over people, right?
Okay.
I Dunno. Cocktail party,
just call it what it is.
We're getting away from our kids to get
shit faced for a few hours. All right?
And somebody's going to try
to dominate the conversation.
Somebody is going to
fucking bring up politics.
Someone's going to get too drunk.
Then there's going to be a fucking
argument and there's got to be apologies
afterwards. Why doesn't everybody just
pick a fucking corner of the room? Okay.
Stare at the carpet and just
start drinking. Okay. That's it.
Why else would we here is
this some swingers party?
We going to trade off here?
Like what? What is going
on? I don't, Maggie,
I don't give a shit about your
worldview. You don't hold public office.
You do not have access to top
secret documents in the Pentagon.
So at the end of the day,
what am I doing here?
And I really listening to like a nurse
trying to tell me how to fix a car.
Isn't that kind of the same thing?
Would you like to hear what I think
about fucking the Middle East?
Cos You wouldn't lie right
there. Finish your fucking drink.
Um, anyways. Uh, what else is going on
this weekend? Oh, I'm going to be in,
I'm going to be in San
Antonio, but not one show.
Two shows at the majestic theater.
Oh my God. It's so majestic.
They added a second show.
I'm going to be doing some morning radio
tomorrow to hype that second show, um,
doing that one show. I'm doing
two shows like Brad Marshawn.
I'm not going to fucking
stab you in one ball.
I'm stabbing into not going
to get suspended for one game.
You're suspended for it. I'm
gonna do one show for every game.
Brad Marshawn was suspended. Okay.
Was unfairly targeted because he in a,
in a moment of emotion, he used the
shoveling, the snow fucking technique,
and he did not have the Sidney Crosby
pouty lips for when he went to the board
in New York. I think that's what
Crosby does. You know, he just,
he doesn't even have to go to New York.
They just fucking put him on Skype and
he just sits there like, hi guys. Oh,
I'm sorry. You know, I was
just having a bad period.
Oh, isn't it amazing how much I could
talk without even know what the fuck? Um,
I ain't know what I'm
talking about here. Um, Hey,
do you guys want to know how to
change a shitty diaper properly?
Are there any parents out there? Here's
one to grow on. Here's one of my,
here's a tip for you. All
right? What happens is,
is when you have a little base,
say the word, say the God damn
fucking Raj, I'm going to be out. Uh,
if you have a baby, um,
and you're breastfeeding it as
opposed to giving it formula,
I'm staying away from that shit. I just,
I don't like that fucking name
formula at that fucking name alone.
I'm not giving my baby formula. You know,
I would just picture like one of those
Frankenstein movies with the graduated
syndrome cylinder and the dry dry ice
smoke coming out of the top of it.
So anyways, so they bait. Yeah,
they got a liquid diet going on.
So when you know, when the fucking
backdoor comes off the hinges,
as they say, uh, you
know, this is the deal.
The second you hear the fucking,
you know the rumblings in the grumblings,
what you gotta do is you gotta
get your kid not horizontal.
You got to have them upright. All right?
Now this is the problem when you
take them down to the changing table,
when you lay them back down again,
okay? And you take an off the one Z,
you got to elevate him a little
bit. You know, as they say,
shit runs down hill. Okay?
So what you want to do is you want
to use gravity as a favor. This,
it's a two person job.
If you're going to save that
fucking onesy all right?
Which you got to do is you have to have
the baby fucking standing up on the
change in table. All right?
The other person on does the onesy lifts
the onesy up over the fucking diaper,
and then you'd take the diaper off like
you'd taken the transmission out of a
car that's up on a lift. All right? Then
you use gravity. Everything drops down.
I'm trying to be as not graphic
as humanly possible. Okay?
Then you know, then you
begin the fucking, uh,
the restoration
because I'm telling you right now,
if you're home alone, all right?
And you lay that kid down,
then one shit runs downhill.
Now what's on the One z?
You got to take it off.
You got to go over the kid's fucking
head and now you got shit on the fucking,
I'm sorry. And this is what it is. I
don't want to put shit on the kid's head.
Okay?
I'll tell you it's a rough one. You know,
so fortunately if that fucking app is,
is somebody else around, I'm sorry,
I didn't mean to get that graphic,
but you know, people who are parents of
telling you just one person holds it up,
the undo the ones, he, you dropped the
diaper out like a fucking trans mission,
you know, do a little cleanup.
Then you fucking set the kid down,
then you finish the fucking
clean up, Bam. A new diaper.
Actually you don't even do that.
Usually we just bring her into the fucking
shower and start all over again with
a brand new squeaky clean
fucking kid. And there you go.
There's a little percent. That's my first
per unsolicited parental advice. Okay.
I just felt like for me, I just
felt like it needed to be sad.
Okay.
Is anybody watching that
reality show? Black ink? Uh,
my wife watches it all the time.
There is a woman on there that makes
my temper look like a fucking summer
breeze.
Good Lord that she lose her fucking shit.
It's like she's possessed. Um,
I actually just said literally have to
walk around a little, but I, you know,
I keep forgetting this
show. I started the watch,
I watched the first three episodes and
I absolutely fucking loved it and I
tweeted about it. It was a cartoon from
Japan, I guess they're called anime,
which I did know that,
but I didn't realize it was
such a divisive thing to
say that you like to show
that was anime. I feel like is animated
like the Emo of fucking cartoons.
Like I tweeted that, I liked
this show called one punch man.
All right. And the fucking
responses that I got, I got, dude,
are you fucking drunk? Oh
my God, you're in the enemy.
And then other people just like
this is like the create it. However,
I just like to show,
I've watched enough for the same type of
shit and I was scrolling through and I
was like, what the fuck is this show?
And I looked and it had five stars,
four and a half, five stars,
which is why I really hope Netflix
doesn't go to thumbs up, thumbs down.
Like I said, because it's so
fucking, you know, stubbing your toe,
thumbs down, Adolf Hitler, thumbs
down. I mean the thumbs down is,
this is a big gap between
Hitler and the, you know,
stubborn your fucking toe. Um, anyway,
so I put this thing on and
what I loved about the show,
um,
aside from the fact that I really thought
it was funny that you actually kind of
got like a sense of what young people
feel like in Japan as far as their view
of going into the corporate world was
very similar to the empty feeling unless
you're a fucking sociopath over here.
I find like a very like common thread to
that and to basically give the overall
thing the superhero in it. He's not a
suit. He doesn't want to be a superhero.
All right.
Any fucking trained really hard cause
he wanted to be the strongest guy in the
world. And in his training he lost
all his hair, which is hilarious.
And he's really self conscious about it.
But he ended up developing
like this punch.
And no matter what monster he runs into,
he doesn't give a shit
whether they kill him.
He's just completely devoid of
any like passion or emotion.
Like what happens to you when you get
shoved into a fucking cubicle and a,
and he's got this one punch and he just
fucking can punch so hard that no matter
how fucking Badass the
monster is, he gives him one,
somebody said they should have called
the show, the right they have Fred,
he gives him the fucking
Brian in the fucking,
in the face is Eddie Murphy
says in the face, um,
and their fucking head explodes
and the monsters that he fights,
you also get more of an insight
into where people's heads are at,
uh, in Japan. And it was like, you know,
one of the monsters you fought with,
some giant virus sent here by
the Earth to get rid of the,
all the humans cause of what
we'd done to the planet.
So there's an environmental thing.
Then my favorite one was
this guy who was crab man.
He was half like up top and he was all
a crab. And then the bottom, he was,
he was half a guy and he
was in, but the bottom half,
he's in his bare feet and tidy
whities and the guy's like,
oh, I ate so much crab meat
that I became a fucking crab.
And to me he represented the
upper 1% corporate guys, you know,
on some power lunch. Just eaten all the
fucking Sushi and just take, take, take,
take, take, nothing spiritual about
them. So he gave him the all right there,
Fred.
And then he fought this fucking lady and
she had command of all the mosquitoes
and she'd stick the mosquitoes
on everybody suck all
the blood out of you and
all your fucking energy. And
then it would make her stronger.
And to me it's like, oh, this is a gold
digging blood sucking whore. Right.
And then once she got it to do it to
all the animals and everybody there,
she didn't need them mosquitoes anymore.
She told all the mosquitoes
to go fuck themselves.
And I'm like slash this is also somebody
who becomes successful and forgets
where they come from. And they look
at everybody where they used to be.
It's like a Bunch of Fucking pee ons,
a bunch of little insignificant
little mosquitoes. Right?
It's a lot of levels to it.
Or he just get fucking high and watch
this bald headed dude fucking punch half a
crab in the head and wants
you to explode. I enjoyed it.
Right.
Let's do a fucking advertising here
before I wrap up and I talk about moto GP
and the [inaudible] in Chinese
Grand Prix and a my glutes.
All right, Luke crate
everybody. Uh, give me a little,
are you on a quest or an EP for epic
gear, housewares and collectibles. Oh,
do you have a one punch man t shirt?
This is finally gonna fucking make
sense to me. Luke crate has it.
The best surprise, you know,
is coming Lou crate operas an epic range
of pop culture items for less than $20
a month.
If you're more of a fanatical fashion
Easter than a then try loot wear monthly
wearables and accessories with Koch
classics and your favorite franchises.
Do you want to get fancy?
Get a bigger box with an even
bigger loot with Luke crate DX.
Want to kick out your pet. Try loot pets.
Offer expires April 19th at
9:00 PM Pacific for April.
Join us as we salute one of our
favorite mystery solvers with items from
strangers, things, Batman,
the x files and Marvels Jessica Jones
to get some one man punch shit in there.
One lucky subscriber.
We're also win a mega crate including
signed copies of Jessica Jones alias
volumes one through four Oh Jessica
Jones alias volumes one through four.
I no like I might as well be
reading a different language.
I have no idea what any of this
shit is other than stranger things.
And I know Batman and I used to
know this chick named Jessica. Uh,
you have until the 19th
at 9:00 PM Pacific.
He just said this to subscribe and
receive that month's crate and when the
cutoff happens, that's it.
It's Oh go to [inaudible] dot
com slash burn enter my code.
Berbee you are our to save $3 off any
new subscription today. All right,
here we go. Here we go. How many of
these fucking things I got to read.
All right, lift everybody. L Y
L to the motherfucking y, f. T.
You know about Lyft, right?
It's the app that gets you a ride in
minutes on demand 24 seven for less than
the cost of a cab. Please include all
of the falling points during your week.
Well, if it takes too long, I'm not. If
you tried Lyft, you know what I mean?
With Lyft, you got, you
just download the app,
ProQuest a driver and they show up in
three and a half minutes. On average.
That's really fast. You know,
unless there's a fucking guy chasing
you with an ax and that's probably takes
forever.
Every Lyft driver is fully vetted
through their 10 point safety standard,
including criminal and DMV
background checks. You know,
you'll get around quickly and safely
other than that other one, ah,
that rhymes with mover Lyft drive.
Drivers are rated after every ride,
so the only the best stick around.
You don't have to worry about getting
into a filthy car with some creepy dude.
With Lyft, you can tip in the app, which
obviously leads to happier drivers.
I mean,
nine out of 10 Lyft rides get a perfect
five star rating from the passenger yet
it's just a better all around
experience. Bigger isn't always better.
Lyft isn't the biggest
riding ride sharing app,
but it's the fastest growing
and the highest rate of one.
I'm talking about quality
over quantity. Thanks to Lyft,
you got an easy way to avoid drunk
driving. You never have to bum a ride.
You never have to worry about parking.
A lot of people are actually getting
rid of their cars and relying on Lyft to
get around. And you know
what? I don't blame them.
Evidently right now Lyft is offering
our listeners a special offer deal.
Get three rides up to $10 each.
There's a up to a $30 a fucking dollar
value when you answer that Promo Code
Bell Barf. People don't want
to listen to this fucking long.
That's Promo Code Bill Bird.
Enter Promo Code Bill Berg
cut to the fucking chase.
All right. He looks everybody. It's a
one punch. A fucking reference. Alright.
Helix. Helix. I Dunno, you're unique.
You're a special little snowflake.
Take a bath and reconnect with yourself.
You don't walk like anyone else.
Top block anyone out or
asleep like anyone else.
So why is your mattress one
size fits all? I don't know,
cause there's an average height of a
human being because it truly customized
mattress will cost you five to 10,000
bucks. Ooh, I didn't know that until now.
Go to Hellickson Helix, sleep.com.
Answer a few simple questions and they'll
run a three d biomechanical model of
your body through their proprietary
algorithms they've developed with the help
of the world's leading arrogant comics
and biomechanics experts. The results,
there's a fucking robot that looks like
you walking around blowing Donald Trump
and eventually they get rid
of you. But in the meantime,
you're sleeping on the most comfortable
mattress you've ever slept on.
He likes sleep. He likes customers.
Report a 30% improvement
in overall sleep quality.
How do you tell how to eat? I guess
when you wake up in the morning,
how much better you feel and for cuffs,
customers, you know what happens is,
is when you're sleeping, right?
When you're going to do the survey,
that robot that they made,
a you comes in and fucking jerk shoe off
while you sleep and you wake up like,
oh my God, I'm so fucking relaxed. And
then once you give the approval rating,
that robot leaves. That's it. That's
how they do it. And for couples,
they customize each side of the mattress.
Your mattress arrives at your door
in about a week and shipping is free,
100% free.
That's why everyone from GQ magazines
to Forbes are all talking about helix
sleep. Helux a, you have 100 nights to
try it out and if you don't love it,
they'll pick it up for free and give
you 100% refund. No questions asked.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr
and get $50 off your order. That's helix
sleep.com/bar [inaudible] dot com slash
Berg all right, lastly, but not leastly.
All this is great. I'm trying to lose
weight. I have to do this. Blue Apron,
everybody, not all ingredients
are created equal, fresh,
high quality ingredients.
Make a real difference.
So it's important to know
where your food comes from.
Talk about your personally. I'm going
to do this in the corporate world.
Uncle portrait, personal experience
work. Real work. Demille.
You'll cookie or grade your 12. Raul,
how are treasured hog dollar cookies
or track rockers who don't go to this?
We will not cover you on a pucker
money. Um, this is my experience.
Every time I read it, I want
to try it. I've never done it.
They sent me a gift card.
I'd used the gift card,
but I don't like going on the
Internet trying to figure out shit.
I put it on my wife's desk.
I'm hoping at some point she's going to
come across it and that she will get it.
And at some point some chemo will
show up wrapped in a blue apron.
That's my experience.
Additional points featured as
desired feature as desired. Oh,
do I like this? I get, I get,
I get to choices here for less
than $10 per person, per meal.
Blue Apron delivers seasonal recipes
along with pre-portioned ingredients to
make delicious home cooked meals.
Choose from a variety of new set recipes
each week or let blue aprons culinary
team surprise you. All recipes
are not repeated with any years,
so you'll never get bored.
Customize your fucking recipes each
week based on your preferences.
Blue Apron has several delivery options
so you can choose the one that fits your
needs.
Maybe you can have your fucking helix
robots show up and give you your Goddamn
cous cous and there's no weekly commitment
so you get deliveries whenever you
want them. Each meal comes with step by
step. They'll show you how to cook it.
You can have it done in 40 minutes
or less. They're fucking healthy.
You're going to get your apps.
People will be able to see your apps.
Everybody has apps. If you didn't
have abs, you couldn't sit up in bed.
All right,
check out the two to watch your robot
just running out the door that I just
dreamed that.
Check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals for free with free
shipping by going to blue apron.com/berg
you will love how good it feels and
tastes to create incredible home
cooked meals with blue apron.
So do not wait unless you want to.
That's blue apron.com/burr
blue apron, blue apron.
A better way to cook. That's the
only way to deliver that line.
That's why they have to
call me. You have to pause.
That's old school advertising. You can't
say blue apron. A better way to cook.
You gotta be like Blue Apron.
A better way to cook. Okay,
bill on this take on this tape.
Did you discover the word blue
apron as as a like, like, Ooh,
I didn't know that was
there. Yeah, I can do that.
Can I give you three different reads?
Yeah, that would be great. Okay,
here we go.
Okay.
Blue Apron. A better way to cook
blue apron. A better way to cook
blue apron. A better way to cook.
I was at Philly. Got It. Okay.
We'll see you next week. Alright,
thank you. Yeah. Hang on a second. Um,
anyways, let me get back to, sorry,
I was just giving you guys a little
behind the scenes on voiceovers.
Did you like that? Did you feel
like you were there? All right,
let me wrap this up. This
weekend I'm for the first time,
I think I'm going to watch an entire
MotoGP race. I believe it's in Argentina.
It's somewhere down south.
[inaudible] I'm all shook up no
further south than that. Good coach.
Go a little samba action.
Yeah.
Who the fuck I'm getting texts
from right now? Oh my God,
I don't remember that person in
a minute. All right. Anyways,
MotoGP and then the Chinese
Grand Prix. Um, this is,
this is a very great weekend before
the, the NFL and NBA playoffs.
If you would like to watch
some alternative sports
sports that are not as big as
the big four here in the United States
of American. Who? Who's kidding,
who are country matters the most?
Therefore our sports matter the most.
All right.
People know our star
athletes around the world.
Nobody knows people in the
premier league. You know,
the only reason why we knew
that one fled Beckham guys,
cause they made a movie about it and
he was fucking one of the spice girls.
All right? If he wasn't fucking
some chicken, a girl band,
nobody knew who that guy was. Okay.
We mattered the most. All right, let's,
let's try to have a little
more empathy as Americans here.
Let's watch some fucking great
sports from around the world.
MotoGP if you want to watch a bunch of
lunatics driving about 180 miles an hour
right next to each other,
taking turns fucking maniacs.
And he also the technology and that
sports, you know, like those suits. Now,
I don't know how they figured it out,
but they figure out that the riders
fallen off the bike and before he hits the
payment pavement, ideally
like the, the, the,
the suit that they wear has like an
air bag that just fucking immediately
inflates and protects all the vitals
in theory. You know, obviously,
I dunno if you fucking slam into a wall.
I don't know what happens then. But,
um, and then the Chinese
Grand Prix, the second race,
the second of 20 races,
there's only 20 races.
It's very easy to watch this and continue
to watch all the other sports that you
love. He can tape it, you can just fucking
watch it. And uh, the Ferrari's one,
the first one was Sebastian Vettel I
believe. And uh, you know, I'm sorry.
I'm sure fucking I'm the fluxes name. Uh,
Lewis Hamilton is not
happy about that shit. Um,
and I was actually going to go to that
tt race this year and the Isle of Man and
ended up fucking falling apart.
So, um, I got to go next year.
I got to go next year before they
make it fucking safe. I have to go.
And if you've never seen that race,
more people have died than
years that they've had it. Um,
the balls these people have,
it's like fucking real
life mad max type shit,
except there's still running water and
all that stuff. Um, anyways. All right,
let me talk about my glutes. Give me a,
this is something I realized
as I'm rehabbing all these
injuries and my body is
that through years of sitting
on planes and sitting on cars,
like I fucking, I have like
no glute muscles whatsoever.
Like beyond the usual fucking
white guy, no ass type of shit.
It's just like my fucking thighs
do all the work. So I've been,
I've been doing these squats where
you kind of push from your heels.
And when I'm coming down and I'm trying
to have most of my weight on my squat,
all my squats on my heels with my
torso, like straight up and down,
not leaning forward to counterbalance
the lack of glute muscle that I have,
I start to come down
into a seating position.
I have to do it like over my workout
bench. Cause if I just tried to go,
you know, mainly depending on my glutes,
I will literally fall down the
like the first 30 degrees I'm okay.
And then I just fall
down to the bench. So I
gotta get that going. Um,
so that's what I've been doing.
I just went on and I looked
up the top 10 glued things,
don't do an alternative leg lunges.
I got an exercise ball up against the
wall that it put on my back and I go all
the way down to a deep squat pushing
up through my heels. Then I do the one,
um, where you lay on your back,
your feet are planted on the ground
and then you, you lift your hips up,
you know, with the glutes that way,
it's almost like you're, you're,
you're sort of thrusting up as
if you were fucking somebody,
you know what I mean? But way up,
like they were lighter than air and
you could actually possibly do that.
So I do those and then I do the
alternative fucking leg lunches.
That's what I'm doing so
far. So hopefully, I dunno,
I had no idea my body was so god
damn fucked up. But evidently it is.
But I am one 77.674 excited
about that and a deal with me.
Everybody come on, the summer's coming
up, lose a couple pounds a week with me.
Cut out the chips, the cookies.
Just fucking drink waters,
sign up for that blue
apron shit. You know,
have a robot come and deliver it to
your house. Be done eating by five,
six o'clock at night. And even
if you get home later, just,
I always try to go like fucking at least
12 hours without eating when I'm trying
to lose weight for like the last day.
Like if I finish eating around seven,
I'm not going to have breakfast
till like fucking nine. Um,
if you do have a day job,
just have like, I don't know,
have like a lighter breakfast
to something like that. I,
I don't know what the
fuck I'm talking about.
All I can tell you is what works for
me. All right. That's the podcast. Uh,
have a great weekend. You can check
out some of the outline. You know,
what else is on this
weekend? The fucking man.
I'm the one golf tournament that
I really try to watch every year.
It starts today. So just, um, you know,
if you don't wanna watch the last couple
of fucking games of hockey, you know,
I know baseball is going in that
type of stuff, but, uh, I dunno,
this racing stuff is pretty fucking
God. Damn cool. All right. That's it.
Go fuck yourselves. We'll see on Monday.
So first he is completely addicted to
skating now and he wants to get better at
it and I'm,
so we're fucking in Edmonton the next
morning we got to drive down to Calgary
and Forrest, he's going like this
gotta be a place here to skate.
So we find out they have, uh, they
have a skating rink at the mall.
And not only is it a mall, it's one of
the most giant malls in North America.
America. Yeah. West Edmonton
Mall rivaling. Uh, what's
that one in Minnesota.
Mall of America. Mall of
America. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. So,
which I've been to that one
too. So we go to that one.
We're walking through there
with our fucking skates,
two middle aged guys walking through
this thing with fucking skates. And, uh,
we walk in, there's like this giant
pirate ship. I mean like, yeah,
you could sail the fucking ocean
with this fucking thing. Yeah.
It was a fuck alone special.
And I look on the other side,
it was really deep water and they took
all this time to make it look like there
was a ship rapping. Jesus Christ. I
mean like you could fucking, you know,
it was monstrous man. Like Shaq could
drown in this water if he didn't.
That's how fucking deep it was. Huge.
And then we look on the other
side and I'm like, Paul, I'm like,
is that a sea lion?
They had sea lions at this
thing and they're like thrown
it fish and shit. Fish.
And it was catching a train or was don't,
it wasn't like people just walking
by throwing shit from the food court.
It was a trainer throwing it. And um,
so we're just walking through the
mall, walking through the mall.
Endless fuck them all. They had a
water park there. Yeah, it was insane.
I didn't look at any stores. I was too
distracted by the shit in the middle.
And then we finally get all
the way to the ice ice palace.
They called the Ice Palace and we got
all excited and were the only people with
skates just walking through holding a
fucking dumb skates and we get all the way
to the other side versus
all excited like, dude, I'm,
I'm telling you I'm going to get better
at this. You wait, I was getting,
I was ready this summer. He's already
talking, Shit, don't call it right now.
I'm going to be fucking skating
backwards. You're going to be like,
what the fuck happened? [inaudible]
yeah, right. And then we show up and uh,
there's a big judo tournament where the
ice rink is and they'd fucking put all
this floor flooring all over
it. I was in denial. I'm like,
maybe this isn't their rank.
They might acknowledge this dude.
It says ice palace fall. This is
it. They covered it up. This is it.
I got upset though at the mall,
man, member number, that girl, man,
that really bothered me. We were walking
through the food court and you know,
we had a gyro. Great Gyro and yeah, yeah,
a great gyro at this place called
Jimmy the Greek, the one complaint.
And you agreed a little too much white
sauce and it was pasty. Yeah, it wasn't.
Yeah, it was a little pasty. You should
have got one scoop. You went to one,
one scoop lesson, a little hot sauce
and it would have been fuck it.
He got excited. It would have been
epic. Yeah. Well you got excited.
So then I said to bill, you know, I like
a little dessert after I eat. You know,
I like a little candy bar. I like a
little, you know, so I love sugar in tank.
Yeah. So, so I go bill man, it was
it frozen yogurt place. I go, yeah,
pink barriers. I'm just going to go
with frozen yogurt. See? All right,
so we're walking light the picture,
so to middle aged men with skates and
I'm like, you keep saying I'm middle age.
Do you want a middle age?
I'm 30 I just turned 35 35 times
two 70 most guys fucking drop.
Well I call, I call like I call
middle it. Yeah. All right. What,
what would you call it? No, I got, I
guess you're right. I guess, you know,
I always just, when I thought of it
as a kid, I always felt, you know,
it was no, I don't know. I just
remember, dude, I, it's, I dunno,
we'll just say 40 forties but I,
you know, bought e's for to people.
Do people live long, man, dude,
I'm fucking be 46 46 times two
is 92 you're going to really,
I can't really sit there
and say, I'm middle age.
Tell you the way I'm eating
and smoking. Yeah, no,
no. So, so we walked through
and we were like, where is that?
Where was that frozen yogurt place?
Let's go to that frozen yogurt place.
So we too, we see two young
women walk by and we figure, Hey,
I looked at him and I'm like,
these, these, these ladies,
they're going to know where they're
going to know where a pink berry is.
So we walk up and you go first. You say
to the friend, you go, hey, you got,
you guys know her. Oh that good. That
good looking too, by the way. Yeah.
I've got good looking girls and
you go up first, you go, hey,
you guys know where the frozen yogurt
places and like she did like a double take
. Like she did a double take, so fucking
rude, right? And she was like, what?
And then I looked at the other one
and I go, yeah, like a pink berry.
And she kind of just like gives a shake
off. Like how would I know? Like why?
And she fucking did. This is what she
did. She did the classic pretty girl,
you're clearly just asking me this
because you want to talk to me thing.
And I'm like, no bitch, I want some
fucking yogurt. Okay, I want fucking,
I want fucking treat. You know, I just
had lunch and it really bothered me,
dude. And we were walking
around and I wanted to find her.
I wanted to find past this again.
They did the loop on the fight.
I didn't know that, but I said to
bill when we got to the car, I go,
I wanted to find it. Cause I
would've just went up there and go,
you know something. I found it. And
you're a mean jerk and then you go,
why would you do that? You're
a mean jerk. That's terrible.
What am I gonna call her a cunt?
Well, don't call her anything if you're
going to go with me and jerk. I mean,
you know, I hate that you're, you're
on that pretty good state. Your main,
but you're a jerk if you want to stay
clean. But if you go, you're a mean jerk.
No, you're not. You're not. You're not
pretty inside. You're not pretty. Inside.
Doesn't give a fuck. She's
still hot girl at the mall.
Paul put yourself in her fucking pumps.
All right?
With two fucking jackets standing there
with ice skates when there's a judo
tournament down the way,
asking if they know where the
fuck the ice cream store is.
They looked at us the way they were
supposed to. I, you know what, dude?
I like a sweetheart. I don't
care how you [inaudible]
love to hear them tell the story and they
come and then there's just creepy guy
comes up like that's the way
they're going to hear it. Paul.
Paul. Do you ever watch those
fucking prison shows? Which ones?
Like the scared straight? No,
not those ones where they talk about the
worst prisons in the country and that
type of shit. Oh yeah.
I seen a couple of them.
And you just sit there watching it going,
how the fuck would I go in there and
not get raped? What would my game plan?
He gets scared watching
it in your bedroom, right?
Women have to walk out of
the house worried about that.
That somebody is gonna
do. Just imagine if our,
I did. I had a winter hat on with a puffy
ball on top of it. Holding Ice Skates,
asking for yogurt. If anything, she
probably thought I was fucking gay.
[inaudible] you don't
look gay, Paul. I know,
but you're not asking that question
that your beards to terrorists.
You need to get a little more
metro-sexual. I going to do that. We was,
we had sweatpants on though. We were
a mess. Everybody in the fucking girl.
Yeah, that's what you love my beard.
My beard actually fucking says everybody
on the fucking ground. No, but dude,
I don't like the pretty girl who can't
be approached with a question because Oh,
this guy's hitting on me. It's, it's
awful. And he knows something that got,
especially the blonde one who went
like shook her head like what?
She's going to be a nightmare. She's a
fucking nightmare for some future guy.
I'm telling you, she's a nightmare.
She's already selfish. It's over.
What if she just knows what
she wants and we're not at
fault. Well
this is the thing dude,
you actually aloud like how old do you
think they were would probably 2122 yeah.
You let at 2122 year old.
I met girl at my age, not even a one way.
She shook it all that and let it ruin
like the two we're driving down to
Calgary. Yeah, she ruins,
we got the rocky mountains on the right
hand side of the car and you're just
still calling. You're calling
her a cunt the whole way down
and father the shit out of me. It was
like, why are you, why would you ask me?
How would I know? Dude. You realize how
funny that is that they did that to us?
Like what? Like yeah, they
really made us feel like shit.
That's fucking hilarious.
If you look at it,
it bothered and the whole time it's
cause you wanted to get frozen yogurt.
That how funny would it be if
we chased him down and I went,
you got frozen yogurt with
sugar-free gummy bears on it.
It was still all natural,
no organic gummy bears.
How great would it be if we chased him
down and I just walked up to her and I
go, you know something,
you hurt my feelings.
It just fucking broke down.
You know, you hurt my feelings.
It just want a yogurt. By the
way, from people listening here,
this is last week, you know,
you know, just trying to kill,
just trying to make jokes to not go out
of your mind being on tour this fucking
long. Yeah. As we were doing the danger
fields, everything. Oh, I'll tell you,
I've got a friend of mine
loves yogurt, you know,
so we were doing that and once
that went away, that got old.
Somewhere along the line.
You started doing it,
you started saying really sentimental
shit to me and then pretending like you
were crying and then that just became
like the running joke and then you started
laughing and then you were just
like, you got to do that onstage.
Do that cry and think. So now we'll
just go up and like if we'll be like,
hey man, I'm tired, but too,
you know what? Hang on, hang on.
What you on the road has been great.
You're the only one I
could have done it with
and then bill would come and
tag it. That's the best thing.
Bill would come and tag hour to do it. Oh,
I was hoping you were going to
say that, but go to, it's been,
it's been fucking wonderful for my anger.
I'm going to try to do that when I get
home. Just pretend like I'm crying, man.
It's fucking hilarious. So two stories.
We go in to eat and we have this
Filipino waiter, right? By the way,
I like to play the Games where I sorta
hell, where are we? Was that Edmonton?
Was that Calgary? That was
Edmonton. Yeah. Was Edmondson.
So I like to do this thing where
sometimes I like to fuck with people,
so I'll just get on a phone
and I'll be like, Bill,
go along with it and we'll be in
an elevator and I'll go, what? No,
that's horse shit. And like bill just
be like, what happened? So like I said,
like he had a parole officer called
and he said, and bill goes, oh,
they worked it up. And
then instantly Burgos yeah,
but what about that
video tape? I go, no, no.
They said it's in submissive and like,
and like the guy there was
just a stranger there. Right.
Sometimes I break out
laughing, so bill calls it,
he gets a little emotional guy. So we
turn this crying thing, we do it to like,
this is big. Great, right? We turn it,
we turn that into doing it in public.
So we have this Filipino waiter,
right. And the whole guy guy was great.
He was talking to us and at the end
I just go, he goes, here's your bill.
And I go, I just want to say so.
And I kept a dead straight face.
Like you've been a great waiter, man.
And I put my hand on his fucking
arm and I got you. You know what?
You're bringing the waters and bill just
looks at and goes. He gets a little,
he gets a little emotional, you
know what I mean? I know, but it's,
it means a lot. Guy Didn't
know what that I had no,
cause he was so fucking polite. Eddie
was actually from the Philippines,
so he's [inaudible] jumped
right in perfectly to my friend.
He gets a little emotional, but not
Billy. He'd been the waters dude who,
he was freaked out though. Oh,
that's the new game on the road.
You had the best one. I got to say, the
best one was at the airport yesterday.
We got to the airport yesterday and
bill starts busting my balls about my
laundry and he goes, Versie fucking
16 days and you're carrying, you know,
dirty socks and underwear. And I
go, dude, I go, I bought new ones.
You know the dirty ones
are tied up tight in a,
in a plastic bag and bill just goes,
just secure emotions. And Dude,
I fucking could not walk.
I couldn't walk and I had to stop pulling
my fucking the bag I'd checked cause
we were laughing so hard. [inaudible]
work Stowe, it makes, it makes,
it's fucking great. It's driving
a tour manager nuts. Oh yeah.
That's the ones that we will because
women don't want to see a guy getting
emotional like that. It's just, well no,
because once somebody cries it's over.
You know,
like when I go out afterwards and I'm
taking pictures with people and stuff,
I always come back. I was just
saying, I got to tell you, you know,
I've seen a lot of people do that,
you know, doing the picture thing,
but you gotta be one of the best
wives. She's going, would
you stop fucking doing that?
Our lives are going to go nuts cause
you know, the first thing I want,
I see stays and you see your wife. We're
just going to go. It's been so long.
I miss you so much. No, you got it.
You got to set it up with talking,
like you said, to start off
normal, what you're going to say.
Something really sentimental to them. So
they're almost crying and then you cry,
which ruins their crime. And I swear to
God, you get slugged in the shoulder,
which is all you really want. Oh Shit.
20 minutes in. I'll tell you Paul,
you know, time really flies with
you on the pool. It's been so fun.
This is probably only funny to
us, but I don't give a shit.
Try it with your friends. Oh fuck that.
If people gain, if the game is called,
he gets emotional and
just walk into a bar.
Just have one of your friends
started hitting on a woman and then,
and then the other friend's
got to go along. Yeah.
And then just starts welling up and
then the other guy goes, I'm sorry.
He just gets emotional and you just got
to let the other person deal with it.
Dude,
you'll want at the fucking airport where
you walked up to that lady at the car,
the little fucking I sell gum, whatever
the hell it is. And she said, excuse me,
do you have the, I have the, what are
the biggest night I broke out here I go,
hey man, how you doing?
What are the biggest condoms you got
and what's the biggest size condoms you
have?
I turned around and walked the one you
turned around and walked away and I'm
just staring at her and I'm biting my
tongue as hard as I can to not laugh.
And then I just burst out
laughing and she said, what?
And then when you went to repeat it,
you try to point to it and I lost it.
You lost it and had to walk away.
Paula punchdrunk out here. You don't,
one of my favorite things in this business
was opie from the opion Anthony show
was he had this thing that he would do
when guys would start crying when they
would play audio. Yeah. Oh my God. It
was fun. And his timing was perfect.
Every time someone would be
talking like retiring from a sport,
like when Mike Schmidt
retired, which is, you know,
it's very difficult to watch.
He was like, you know, you know,
he just was ending as like 38 years ago,
a little boy began a journey to play the
wonderful game of baseball and that the
oop would always go, oh boy.
Yeah,
what am I favorite? And it always,
oh boy, it always meant right.
Nobody wants to see a man just completely,
you know what it is. I can watch a guy
cry if something terrible is happening.
Just don't try to talk while you're
crying. No. That's the thing.
The talking and then bursting out into
cross. Let your shoulders go. Yeah,
let me shut fucking crying, but
don't foe for the love of God a man.
You got to try and manage the cry in
private. Yeah, you do that in the shower.
You do it in the shower. Like when
my son was born, everyone's like,
did you cry yet? And I'm like,
no, what are you talking about?
And then when my son was born,
it all hit me later and I went home to
go get stuff from my wife in the hospital
and I sat on the couch and I
didn't like weep. But I just,
okay,
I didn't weep, but I got emotional.
But love just fixing you sitting on the
couch by yourself and just used to go.
That's stupid.
It's just completely unexpected to
use your thing from your podcast. Oh,
that's unexplored. Z effect.
Unacceptable dude on a
completely [inaudible] right.
Don't talk into it. Right.
Yeah. The talk into it. That's, that's
what the funny thing about crying is,
you know? Yeah. You know,
you always do this to me.
You know you always do this to me and
I'm trying my best and it's over. Yeah,
it's fucking over. Whenever my friends
die, I've had so many of fucker died.
I just cry in the shower. Yes. Right
though I asked the girl, we asked a girl.
Right,
because you don't feel like you're crying
cause there's all that water on your
face anyways.
Okay.
No, we asked the girl, we go, what would
you do if your dude started crying?
Like if it wasn't, if nobody died,
if a dude and you were just arguing,
you just had a bad day and he just had
a bad day and you got into and he broke
down and cry and she goes,
yeah, no, over, over, over,
get the fuck away from me. Yeah. You
know what's funny? There's some women,
they think that they want to see
that part of you. They don't.
What that is to them is that's
their total conquest. Yeah.
You know when you bang a girl in the ass,
you just like, yeah, I got this shit.
I'm fucking with you. Their
version was that Jesus built,
no, fuck we do. Their version of that is,
is if they can get you to be so vulnerable
around them that you cry and then
it's one of those things. It's always
like when the crowd screams out of joke,
they already heard,
they think they want to hear it again
and then you tell it's like, Huh. Yeah.
It wasn't as good. No. It's the same
thing as that. Yeah. You said something,
you said something about
like if a burglar comes in,
if you cry in front of a
woman, all in her mind is like,
what if the Burger comes in at this
fucking guy? Yeah, no, it's over.
You can't cry. You Strip a
woman a security if you cry
in front of her. I think,
I don't think I've cried. I think
my wife's on that. That's a great,
that's what it is. Yeah. You Strip her
of her security cause she's like, oh,
I got this fucking,
yeah, this funny crisis.
This baby sleeping next to you every
night, you know? Yeah. It's, it's over.
You know what I mean? I know you just,
you might as well just have
a pullover sweater, you know,
walking around and then she mocks
you. What are you going to cry, bitch?
Yeah, you saw me?
Yeah, it's fucking over,
dude. You can't have that.
Have you ever cried alone listening
to a song or like, not cried,
but have you ever been like, oh no,
I've completely broken down and I've
told her three cars just weeping
uncontrollably. Have I? Yeah,
totally cry. No, no, I definitely
teared up. Listen, as an, as an artist,
at some point you're going to have
to go to those emotions. You need to,
you need to be, you need to meet
too with your instrument. I have, I,
what was the once like I had
this weird thing where, um,
I stopped crying at some point.
I don't know when I stopped crying
and got mad more when I got hurt in my
brother, beat the shit out of me. Um,
you know that most of the crying I be
just like at the end of it. But I wasn't,
but I wasn't crying and then I didn't cry
ever. One time my brother
is bigger than me.
My little brother was bigger than me.
Right. Big Dog like, and I remember he,
I said, I said, if you fucking take my
clothes again, if you take my clothes,
like he did it every day he would go
into my room, he would take my belt,
he would take my clothes and I'd come
home and I guess in a boy band and I need
to go, I need to go out. Right.
And I go, mom, if he does it again,
I'm fucking hitting him. Her and
my mom be like, oh, you know,
and one time I need really needed a shirt
and I'm fucking throwing shit through
the house.
And he gets out of his friend's car and
he starts walking up and he's got it on
and I fucking snapped.
And my grandmother was there and I jumped
on him and I started punching him and
he stood up. He just goes,
what you made your older brother
crying on? My younger brother. Oh,
he's bigger than me. But
he didn't know what to do.
He got so upset that he just got,
and he looked around and he just,
he was so angry that something
needed to come out. And he just goes,
what did you feel bad?
And you start laughing.
I kind of just walked away and you
know, we laughed about it afterwards,
but to now, now he's a, he's a
fuck. He's a big kid. But you know,
my mom had the opposite. I got a little
brother, man, he's an animal, you know?
Nope. My mom says she went to,
she went to a funeral once and everybody
was there and everybody was crying and
she was overwhelmed with emotion that
they had to fucking drag her out.
She said she had them all.
One of the most embarrassing things
happened to her where she said she
uncontrollably laughed because they
said that that can happen sometimes.
So she's sitting there,
she's sitting there and everybody's
crying and like she went up and she could
not stop laughing and like she and I
said, why? Like? And she was like, Paul,
I just don't know. She goes,
I could not stop laughing and
I had to walk me out and like,
and she just is your mom? Yes.
She said because the emotions
or soundbites that they
said that that can happen
sometimes where it just, you just
like, she didn't know what to do.
So instead of just breaking down, she
went the other way and just couldn't,
couldn't control herself. Like humans
will protect you and a really like,
that's what they don't get sometimes
when comics make fucking horrific jokes
about some bad event. Make good jokes.
Yeah. It's about a horrific event.
So they go that so fucking me, it's
a defense mechanism. It's my mom.
My mom is a sweetheart who felt bad and
her emotions just went the other way.
And she goes, Paul, I felt so
bad. I couldn't control myself.
I couldn't control myself. I hate to
say this cause somebody lost somebody.
But there was, if there was video
of that, oh my God. Oh I'm so,
I was saying, so I stumbled
around, I don't know,
10 or 11 I didn't cry for years.
Years and years and years.
And I didn't, I didn't cry until
a friend of mine killed himself.
And even then I was sad and
it's just, Oh, I went, ah,
I was in the bathroom once
again. Yeah. And it was in there.
And I remember I started to cry and
then I started thinking like, wow,
I'm crying. I haven't
cried in a long time.
And then I stopped cause I got out of it
cause I stopped thinking about the dude
kill himself. Wow. Yeah. I went 10
years without a cry and then I had one,
what was it over yogurt. Gummy bears?
No. Uh, I think yeah,
might have been almost,
it might've been one of
my son was born, you know,
it might've been my second one. That's
acceptable. I guess it's acceptable.
I got it other than when I went down
the pool, cause I go down to the pool,
I'm down there to me it's fucking Jay law
head who's been killing it in front of
me and a the lovely Nia and her cousins
and we're hang all right cousin.
I mean we're hanging out down the
pool and they're doing the usual shit.
You know, if you're a redhead
and you go down to the pool,
like you just asked for it.
People that all, you know,
look how white you are. You
know? Like I never noticed.
It's like I'm fucking around myself.
I've been around myself since the sixties
the late sixties I know how white I am
and if I ever forget how white I am,
there's always somebody that remind me.
Sorry, I don't know if you've noticed
your skin tone. What am I meditating?
Floating up on my body. All right,
so these people up with go, come on.
Come on in the pool and like,
I don't want to go in the pool.
I don't want to go in the fucking
pool. You know? They're like, why? No,
why don't you want to go in the
pool? You know, why? Cause a fucking,
okay,
look, look at these people. Look at
them, look at them. And you're gay.
You're getting your, you know,
would you take a bath with aught,
with any one of the
people that you see here?
These fucking just messes of human beings.
There's not enough chlorine in a fucking
pool to kill whatever the fuck they're
dragging in the pool, you know? And
so I finally end up going to the pool.
Then everybody made fun of how white
my fucking alabaster chest was at.
Then I had to stay in the shade of
the fucking, uh, the lifeguards chair,
you know, you know,
I had a show to do, I'm being a
professional, I can't come up stage later,
half in the bag, looking
like, oh, lobster, right?
I got to do my little song and dance
later on that night. So anyway,
so I ended up getting in the fucking
pool against my, what I wanted to do,
you know, and then I get out of the pool.
First of all, for my age, I
am in absolutely phenomenal.
Top shelf shape. Alright.
I gotta tell you the, the
fucking, just the touch stuff.
Fuck the humanity that I
saw poolside in Las Vegas,
the fucking humanity
keyword manatee.
Yeah.
Not The skip step on a Jim Gaffigan.
I just realized he used to use that
reference and I'm pretty sure he used it.
I can't remember how the fuck he used it,
but if he used it to
describe a fat Pale Torso,
not really pale, but whatever,
whatever the fucking shit.
I saw the side of that.
He was dead on that.
Oh my God.
Is there anything worse than seeing
a tattoo come of age? You know,
Jesus Christ, if you get
a tattoo, you better.
You better just make the mental decision
that you're going to P90x for the rest
of your fucking life because
when you don't do it,
I saw this guy down at
the pool. All right.
He had like not only the worst
tattoos you've ever seen in your life,
like the worst placement,
you know what I mean?
Like you get one like or the side of
your arm up by your shoulder that looks
good, right on the bicep. That
looks good. You know, CIOs,
somebody got gets one
right over their voice box.
Like I don't give a fuck what
you have surrounding that.
That leads into that part of
the, of of the work or the piece,
whatever they call it. It looks fucking
horrible. Leg Tattoos, horrific,
horrific. So this fucking jerk off.
He has basically the exact sort of
like tribal thing that the rock has,
except he doesn't look tribal. He
looks like an accountant, you know,
and he doesn't work out.
So just imagine if the
rock was his pasty as I was
and it never worked down in his life,
but it has that saved tattoo that
starts at the elbow, goes up the arm,
over the shoulder and
covers one whole peck.
But the way this guy had it done was
it didn't cover his whole packet,
came swinging in and went right
above his, his man nipple.
So now all of the, all of
that is like colored in.
So because of the pasting
that's of his torso,
your eye is just drawn
to his right nipple.
Is he standing in the fucking pool?
My neck was sore from shaking
my head at people. It was,
it was absolutely fucking
horrific. Right? So anyways,
um, I go back up to the, uh, I go back
up to the hotel room. Right? You know,
you gotta make sure that I'm all shipshape
from my goddamn show and I put on the
news and what are they ended
up doing a story about,
they start doing a story
about the amount of, uh,
fecal matter found in public pools
right after I just got out of
a goddamned pool. You know,
and I know what people always think,
oh, stay away from where the kids are.
Stay away from the Kitty Pool
Rights. Stay away from that.
They always blame the fucking
kids. Will I, you know,
something that after seeing
what I saw poolside, you know,
there weren't a lot of kids
in there, but I guarantee you
somebody got a cola. I know this
is fucking disgusting, but people,
you're basically bathing, you
don't see even more fucked up is,
is Vegas is just like, you know,
people fly in from all over the world.
You're taking a fucking
aids bath, you know,
with a shot of fucking a, what the
hell was that shit that came out,
but it killed people so fast
that it just burned out.
Everybody just ran into the woods.
The fuck was that shit called
Ah, Christ. I can't remember a bola.
That's it with a shot
of a bola or whatever.
Food poisoning. I don't know what
it is. A salmon, Ella shower,
whatever the fuck you want to call
it. I'm done with public pools.
The only pool that I will ever
swimming again is my pool.
If I ever get one or the pool of some
hot chip that I want to fucking bang,
cause I have Nias permission. That's
the only way it's going to go down.
Other than that, you know, I'll
just go. I'll just go take a bath.
That way I'm out of the sun, you know,
I'll take a couple of vitamin E pills,
whatever the fuck it is you get from
the sun. Other than skin cancer,
I'm done with it.
You know what America needs to implement
after years and years of calling the
French people smelly. You know?
That's Kinda like the thing when we went
over to France and save their ass for
the second time last century. Oh wait,
did we do it once? We did it one time,
right? I can't fucking
remember. So anyways,
we've always made fun of the
French fathers. They smell.
If you've ever watched a bugs bunny
growing up, man, you saw pepe Le Pew.
If you noticed he had a
French accent, you know,
that's the kind of shit you couldn't
get away with today because of political
correctness. I guess they were basically
saying that you know that they stunk.
But I'll tell you one thing that the
French have when it comes to hygiene over
Americans. All right? Is
the big day. All right?
I can guarantee you, if I ever go
swimming in a public pool again,
it's going to be at France.
Unless there's a bunch of Americans
or I know I've been over to England.
I never saw the day over there, you know?
But they is basically a carwash
for your asshole. And, uh,
you know, it leaves you feeling refreshed,
puts a fucking smile on your
face. And evidently in France,
she's so fucking happy. You
forget to put on deodorant,
but I'll tell you right now, you can jump
in that pool. I bet they're not dead,
but they're not talking about
that shit over there right.